[Music] what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation it is time for genv episode 3
today John how's it going it's going great sir
how are you no no generation joke Coy how are
you generally speaking very well there we go
now we got it ladies and gentlemen you know
what to do leave a like on this video be sure
to subscribe click the notification Bell when
a reaction for genv episode 4 is up here on
this channel we have been very much enjoying
this show episode 1 and two if you did not catch
a reaction to that that is obviously in existence
here fighting the YouTube restrictions it's it's
a fun time here the real rejects right now also
full length through and watch along resn with
your own copy of genv available for super sex
rejects over at our patreon page over there we
cover several shows exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch SS included massive
thank you to all who have joined us thus
far it's one of the absolute greatest ways to
support the Channel unduly all right let's do
[Music]
it underwire bras
shoelaces oh I was Wonder I was thinking this was
the exact same location yeah that's how they tell
us whoa wait a minute he's been aware of
brainwashed every time to forget him Sam
did you know about this compound V stuff no how
could mom and dad do that to us they thought they
were giving us Powers I got a broken [__]
brain oh I could have just been regular man
this show really shows you the suffrage of
being a super drug or no drug you'd still be
weird as it really does feel like the mutant
High version of the bo yeah it really does
yeah Sam stop it okay yikes
dude nice it's a Mortal Kombat fatality try
legitimate so you must get brainwashed every
time to forget I'm guessing go to sleep Jes oh
her memory's been wiped too Andre I'm fine really
I just pushed too many people that's so their
subconscious keeps it so they dream about it
maybe I mean it sounds like they push their minds
down her ability to enchant seems like she's been
Enchanted too brilliant idea to ping my phone
and then save me from my Stone Cold idiocy I
hope these two fall in love it's happening we need
to get them out now if you charge in there you're
going to get caught and then God knows what and
then and think about it for a second no you know
if you guys just did it you'd calm down a lot
of friction and pressure just alleviated please
don't do anything stupid I can't lose you too
oh it begins the road to doing it I love trauma
bonding you know where the magic happens Luke died
like 2 days ago yeah but they're teenagers their
hormones crazy time works differently in the TVA
can she push him last for like hours oh yeah like
keep him under like Dread like a nine enchant him
to be yeah out here oh no she's Madam plasma to
me oh wow oh my God no a brave mave bar you eat
to get big to get small you you must have the
most regulated diet it's funny because every
time I react I have to defecate every time I
read the comments it makes me def no it's not an
eating disorder it's how I get small you hear that
YouTube yes my mom knows yes I'm in control you're
in control stop whenever I want that's why you're
the size of a gummy bear maybe you should take
a break talk to someone get help okay and you
yourself are you going to take a break get help
that's different that's my power right thank you
you're proven her point but I've been pied by
half the school today I'm not pitying you okay
Marie we don't have to do this we could just
focus on classes like you said we can just be
roommates okay it's interesting how their powers
are so rooted in self harm specifically these two
and like would that cause their personality you
think their personality ties their power like I'm
always nature nurture with powers cycal I'm sorry
I'm aware you're not five it's force of habit my
daughter Loved These pure evil you have a daughter
I did I wanted to tell you after that interview
last night I'm so proud of you Marie you did the
right thing Marie when that bottle blonde ambushed
you with that [__] about your sister it was on
Purpose By the way because it's better ratings
if you cry on camera but you didn't let her get
stayed tough showed Poise ratings real low I feel
like it's probably true I want you to come with
me to this Brink fundraiser tonight can meet some
alumni big donors I've never been just smile let
them drone on about themselves no pressure yeah so
she definitely um did some experimentation on her
daughter huh oh yeah 100% that happened I'm just
the girl who was there she's just a freshman note
the tremble to the voice strong and humble steon
back there you're coming with me to the fundraiser
tonight and you're going to butter the ass of
every trustee with your tongue yeah if I could
do something heroic like help people that'll be
good if there's a camera pointed at you yeah got
to do it for the ratings got to do the photo not
the heroism there is financial gain always clicks
Emma oh Ron Layman Emma wait up hold on a second
look I I want to see if the this campus is at all
affected by homelanders recent actions though the
greater World building of like I mean yeah how
season 3 ended yeah I had no right to co-opt your
story okay I apologize I don't trust you wow you
filming this I want everyone to know how sorry I
am wow my hero now's the perfect time to vomit are
you keeping your food L yes Mom I am completely
balanced you look an inch or two shorter than
usual so you might need to add 50 calories okay
I'm just I'm just going to check your height
goodness this is the exact mom she would have
the mom's jacket is a tribute to April or Neal or
Jubilee Easter egg all the above got it there it
is just want to curl up and everyone just when
your father left me for that bir to a child or
when I was fired from the bot Shopping Network did
I curl up and wanted to say I'm sorry Luke was so
nice to me thank God you single-handedly stop
that Monster's murderous frenzy yeah dude what
did you expect you saw the interview everyone
intervie I mean come on come on M I know Luke
was no that's just it you didn't know Luke how
funny he was how much he loved his family how hot
his best friend [Laughter] is this can't be real
this is very uniquely structured I love how much
Luke's still in the show through flashbacks yeah I
haven't seen the show 13 but I feel like it feels
like this 1 yeah oh God yeah probably she would
have never Le violent I should have been there
oh they told me kill himself they convinced him
he that old tell me to feel better I don't want
to feel like this I think this is something you
just have to go through I'm sorry what a [__]
I was going to say how emotionally mature how did
not use her power with the make with the pushing
already just a second who's that it's my parents
I didn't even finish okay do it in the closet man
you can go through walls yeah does he have to
travel through walls naked or can clothes go
with him is he ever doing it and accidentally
goes through the girl I wonder if they like
them better as a boy or a girl she changes they
change I dat both H we wanted to pay our respects
to Brink tonight we know what he meant to you he
thought you were such an upstanding young man jeez
bit on those deep books think deep oh the
a trainers those are magnificent they're
signed you know they sign the bottom
though so it wears off pretty quick
but you know it's there good to know
he would sign the bottom don't wear
those she's even more Perfectly Imperfect
in person you found a real one real ones
John Bernthal man the women are just used and
abused in this show after this Golden Boy mess
I'm not sure how much I'm pledging the focus
on white male Heroes is problematic if you
want more like Marie I don't know if you have
representation yet but here's my card here's
my card culture War to get an N of my card oh too
late guys you missed the window just crashed and
burned lucky Jordan doesn't have laser eyes
with Luke gone this freefor all for number
one is going to get ruthless and you have
a Target on your back you uh put it there
I don't know you could be the first top ranked
freshman in history oh her ambition just coming
to bite her is rough to see this is Courtney
Courtney she is a senior producer at V last
night's interview with your roommate Marie oh
Marie's your roommate oh I didn't know that
yeah real bottled lightning there huh she wants
to talk to you about maybe starring in her next
reality TV show but no one knew about the tragic
underbelly sorry tragic underbelly it's a Rebrand
oh it's a complete and total Rebrand oh God it's
an exploitation you'll love it she's battling her
own sort of internal super villains from the
body oh that is disturbing eating disorder yes
oh that is so cruel yeah isn't that stuff all
a little personal I want emotion I want real
pain she's great I hate her every executive
eaten alive or feeling [Laughter] small oh
man I excuse me I have to I have to vomit for
non-power relation having met you I love the
falsehood and the capitalistic exploitation of
people's emotions that this show really shines
a light on oh so on the surface but I've been in
those meetings Kyle Vogler you have a fine kid a
real go-getter don't let him you it was a holy
Terror as a boy we're from Rochester where are
you from Kyle how much they're just like saying
boy and and like instigating that narrative is
he expected to present his male Jordan at these
things I think so are they expected to present
as male Jord my bad I hate you are part of
the problem petress thanks how do you be in
it you don't ever a I'm really sorry Emma
we've all been there I don't want to just
be roommates and I don't pity you yeah she
wants a friendship I love the setting that
they're having this conversation holding
her underwear through a dress in a stall
like a friends I love this show I don't know
if I can I release release Marie just let
it oh the tinkle C Jordan used to chase Ruby
around the playground trying to kiss her try
getting away with that this day until one day
Ruby whacks him clean in the face what I really
like that this show is also showing when we learn
that the parents were the ones who agreed to give
their kids compound V you are seeing how the the
destruction of the kids not having a choice in
any of this and how it deteriorates them and just
how cruel the parents are oh and then the reaction
used to try dresses together in high school so
maybe we can be wife and wife sorry about this
he can get dramatic nothing to apologize for he's
into it you got a great kid here just going to let
you catch up he's not into it I mean like why
can't it be like inspirational I mean not like
Queen mave but I mean like Queen mave you know
people like the drama maybe you're not like ohol
Mom I mean it's exploiting me I think in the
real world everybody uses everyone and I think
that this could help you in a million ways thank
you wow no I mean yes should taught me how to do
it how to stick my fingers down my go yourself
holy [__] this is fan [__] tasting that's
good reality TV yeah that's what I'm saying it
should be about them stage moms you you you push
somebody for the few boo yes yes I did should
we talk about our intercourse situation sorry
that sounded yes not not now not now later not a
near shot of my dad think they have chemistry I
think they're not supposed to but do and they're
supposed to like in pieces you know what I mean
I think it's calculated I guess I I'm aware
they're acting when they have scenes together
yeah so it's not even really a chemistry question
you're my firstborn son the day you were born was
the best day of my life I thought we were giving
you a gift gift with compound V you did give me a
gift oh I get a lot of kids don't have a choice
but you do wow you can be a boy forever if you
want sometimes I think you change into a girl just
to spite me I was wait exactly for that L waiting
exactly for that line the kid addicted to their
PlayStation close to Olive Garden just for the
bread sticks who've been just Property Brothers
I've never changed Dad I've always just been me
exactly just themselves what a way to address
this with superpowers man and this guy just
saying all the so they're all going to kill their
parents by the end of the season right I think
the episode that's the key to self-acceptance
right [Music] yes like what all I got is this
and what Luke told me before Mur it's not exactly
credible find out where they have Luke's brother
but I can't do it without getting busted but
you can but maybe oh [__] bading idea so you
should forget I said no I'm totally totally in
dude wow like life or death dangerous and you're
freshman but she's being asked to use her powers
to solve a crime actual heroism yeah wow okay so
the GPS tags connect to my phone remember just
Recon no tiny action hero [__] I think this is
where they're keeping him but if you see anything
shady just bail got it get it got it good yeah
I'm just still stoned sweet Jesus oh you must
be extra it's like one glass of champagne but
trunk she on the tray it's
got an Noir poster up eat some
peas whoa that's scary oh no Jesus how
did you not notice him you what a shot
our beloved Brink's death was not just
a trag where the H you go I was getting
some hair dark days in the's history some
dank air in darkness Stars can truly shine
like Marie Maro the guardian of gulin oh
boy and Jordan's in the room what happened
to you parents vodka the expensive [__] you
save for the big swing in and two glasses you
still pay for it free vodka you got to be
real specific it's like communicating with
chpt wow you think they'd have better video editor
n man just throw it all into Windows Movie Maker
Brink didn't just tone my skills he sharpened my
mind he turned me into the Curious intelligent
man oh my god oh yeah squid curious Brink was like
an uncle to my boy one of the real ones hey what
do you thinking know this is my moment did I do
something to piss you off I didn't sleep through
my interview there's some Fu up Sho going on and
that that's why Luke killed Brink because there's
there's this underground hospital where they keep
everybody in who else would be told oh NOS don't
say anothering word about this great like super
tight shot too oh when they decide to go intimate
with their camera you know so powerful they make
oh oh fear oh that switch he does love his son
man a tiny girl is such an interesting
choice why would I do that what does it
mean no I'm I'm real prove it what's the
name of the stuff the animal I love more
than anything when I was little I have no
idea what's your name dip how about dip
dipt on a bike no man favorite movie well you're
a white guy so Godfather Star Wars or sha shank
all [Laughter] three Water World water a man of
taste you're real yes for real holy [__] you
do know this is the dumbest test ever right what
are you what are you doing here you could get in
big trouble now they have chemistry yeah truly
immediately to get you out of hereu no I don't
I don't think so you were literally almost in
a dungeon it's not so bad I've tried to get
out before but people get hurt I get mixed up I
just I started some new meds I think it's better
if I stay here thanks for coming by stoping again
your brother sent me Luke it's like you're either
a hero or a self-imposing threat to society he
wants to get you out so I mean I guess I could
give you the codes to all the security doors
you know the codes yeah dude come on man I
love their interaction but he's got a million
imp pledges Superstar you save my ass your ass
needed saving you slipped after Golden Boy the
donations were going down the toilet and so was
I then one look at that smile of yours and
their wallets just cracked right open Ki has
that effect I'm glad I could be useful to you oh
so useful you're fantastic excuse me oh welcome
to VA put it together who gave that info to the
woman on TV I'm surprised you can walk straight
with everyone's tongue lodged up your ass leave me
alone [__] about me brown noser one uper mommy
and daddy's perfect little hero oh now you yeah
well that's definitely not me because my parents
are dead because I killed them yikes you happy
[__] wow I didn't know I had powers until my
first period I couldn't control the blood and it
sliced through through my mom's body dad came in
same deal I'm the last person who thinks they're
a hero I [__] hate myself half the time and I
just spent the entire night being dragged around
like a show Pony so I'm not in the mood for your
[__] pan to the other girl recording all of
this put it online you got real trauma you can
sit with us trauma sit with us we are the weirdos
Mister we were camping I was nine my parents were
setting at the tent my little brother kept
kicking at my shins I grabbed him by the arm
and I told him to go away and never come back
oh oh no walked right into the woods that was
the first time my power showed up oh is he just
out there did he die not to have that kind of
power your parents shot you up with a
dangerous drug when you were a baby to
make a buck off you no my parents weren't
like that yes they were everyone's parents
are in this universe some people might have
come I killed my grandpa with my Powers what
no you didn't change it to a boy and yeah
I know I was just feeling left out change
it to a girl and you had a heart attack
I see going for that joke so much more
than that it's about being alone at
the end of the world and finding your
Humanity water worlds yes and drinking your own
[Laughter] he reminds me of Evan Peters a lot
see you whenever hope so me too oh she found
a real connection you want some oh can't if
I eat I like Alice in Wonderland hey you're
soing brave thanks you've gotten closer to
rescuing me than Luke ever did the pretty thing
you were probably born with or maybe cosmetic
surgery oh no hide
smaller what did you do it's about
her roommate Emma oh it's all coming
together now they're a team as soon as
they turn off the electricity run what
electricity oh poor kid face
off Andor prison and face off
fire some time oh uh-oh uh-oh oh what are you
doing kiddo what are you doing H yes do something
disgusting holy Christ Thanos yeah Thanos Thanos
take a candy bar go his ear butt go into his ear
yes do it bra well she does anything to
eat unless she eats his brain yeah go for
it did she bring corn what What's happen she
can still Tinker around in there she's going
through yeah she doesn't need a she doesn't need
to go big she can still like mess with some wires
oh just eat some of his brain tissue I love them
they're my two favorite pairing all the supporting
characters are immediately like fascinating this
is the grossest thing possible oh I think he did
it yeah 100% yes so bad sweet oh man man oh
boy all right um wait did I pause it too early
something we missed something in episode one all
right was it post credit scene uh it was like a um
the Ashley was saying something to the camera and
then it was it was something special they shot but
then it Segways into a preview for oh episode two
for for the rest of the season God I don't want to
see yeah so I was like the the thing we missed was
the exclusive thing got uh but I'm glad we missed
it yeah I'd rather watch the show yeah yeah uh
oh yeah that was great in love with the show have
you guys seen uh have you guys seen runaways yeah
big fan it was the first time I felt like an adult
because I was time like I understood the parents
born than the kids the Kristen Stewart movie oh
I love that too you know that's runaways seems
like there would be a lot of different things
called that big Joan Jet fan he's just like this
relates Jo jet not AEL rock and roll when I come
in the man it's a weird tangent but I'm in ch no
runaways is a a really good like the two sets of
protagonist show they wrote it really well yeah
I think that there I think this is the way how we
liking boys to a bunch of other shows and movies
and and mix in with commentary I feel like this
is what it's doing before I mean it's College when
normally you associate that with like high school
sure these other stuff uh but no I thought this
was great I mean a lot of things we talked about
during the reaction itself that I feel like this
show is further uncovering like it doesn't seem
like it's trying it no no I don't want to say I'm
making it sound like they're not putting effort
because it's effortless at what it's doing yeah
it it doesn't feel like they're forcing anything
in here if they're they if anything they are just
magnifying other elements that have already been
established in their other show and really
showcasing that significantly more you know
like the way how they have touched on like the
par the the the relationship that they have with
Starlight and her mom was probably the closest we
got to getting a sense of what the parent child
relationship was like but of also how tough that
can be and it's like depending on what class you
are in uh in society financially of how that can
inform your decision you know if you so there's a
that was one aspect and here you really do get to
see just how tortured uh it can be growing up and
then how they form the these children to morph
into a personality that is not really them like
when you get to the boys and you see the seven
and then as that show progresses it's constantly
about peeling back the layer of everyone there and
you see that all of them are just broken depressed
individuals who are not really in tune with the
real versions of themselves and hear you you're
you're stripping that all back to see the creation
you see the seeds plantet of how that like this is
Origins and and what I what this episode did
for me in terms of universe building in term
because of the mystery because one thing we were
talking about uh last episode was I'm not super
into to the mystery just yet I'm kind of waiting
to see what it's ultimately going to pay off into
and what I think this set up at least for me this
is the school where everyone goes to before they
can even have a shot at becoming a Super uh you
know one that gets to work if you're not part of
the seven or if you're going to be part of some
other team or just have some kind of job or you
know this is where you have to first go through
and now the boys they have already delved into
uncovering vot the corruption there a lot of that
being uh given to the public even the the whole
thing with compound V and this is something that
they have to keep sacred because people still want
to go to the school people still want to feel like
I can become a superhero and stuff and the people
who gave their kids compound V they need them to
go through here to make something of themselves
and this is the season now that they are going
to do expose the corruption and the evilness and
the and the the the the abuse that this school
does and this school That's essential to the boy
Universe right right so it's another thing they
are up yeah like this is an essential ingredient
for the future of the supers you know what I mean
like for for to have any more supers in the future
and especially when you have the boys which is
all about stopping the supers at least I'm like
you know Butcher and everyone else so I think
that as a World building this is an essential
viewing experience mixed in with just great drama
great drama great storytelling and um relatable uh
I keep wanting to say the tech they qualify as
teens young adult teen struggles you know well
I mean the freshmen are still technically teens
yeah yeah and I I think they do an an absolute
excellent job and capturing that loneliness that
adolescent angst uh I I I really think that as a
as a boy Universe show it's very much Essential
I could see how it could fact into the bigger
picture as as opposed to just a spin-off you know
yeah I no please I I think that like as spin-offs
go enriching is always better like uh it's kind
of like with 3D I I hate when 3D does that thing
where it like here's an arrow launching at you
but when it does like you go deeper into the frame
it's way more interesting like it's like looking
into a book and this is doing that narratively
it's giving us a deeper worldview it's enriching
world all the things you were just saying but what
I think I'm most impressed by is every single
episode you're introduced to an entire swarm of
new characters and they're immediately written
so well acted so well and cast so well you hate
or love them so immediately and and I really
like the comic I said I think on episode two um
it introduces entire teams sometimes in an issue
it's it's a book where if you flip a page you've
got a person that within four frames you're like
I have to know enough about them to care this is
doing that as a show and I'm really impressed
that every time we we build on an episode us
hating Jordan's parents makes us more indear to
her which makes that scene of the three of them
talking more interesting us fearing for the dad's
fear of what's going to happen to his son makes us
more invested in Aon and I think that what they're
doing is every single episode is just going deeper
and deeper and deeper so I I don't still care
about the mystery but I know that when they flip
the switch I'm going to because by that point I
care about all the pieces of the puzzle so much
here's why I think it's important why the mystery
is so important um if I could just make one last
point about it is that whenever you're with the
seven and something is happening with VA what does
the seven do they protect it they fight to cover
it up their top rated students you saw it with
Golden Boy you see it with everyone here they're
not interested in protecting yeah yeah they're
interested in uncovering and potentially exposing
the truth the question is will they Expose and I
think a lot of that relies heavily on Marie like
is which side is she going to go down right yeah
and is she going to be a contributor to the to the
exposing part of it she or are we going to watch
her morph into being like Oh you be a perfect
candidate for this time because you will conceal
our secret and that's what I'm I'm enjoying with
the pivots every Arc is like do they go this way
do they go this way and by the end of the episode
you're like I don't know but I know the more like
you know the person more but I like that we're
still zigzagging yeah so I think that that's why
this could be very much crucial that's it's not
really like like okay to me it seems like okay
they're experimenting down their on te okay yeah
this is like nothing really that different then
we we maybe there's more to it but that's kind of
what I what it what I gather it seems kind of that
cliche of what we already saw in like the boys
already you know like like yeah they're they have
prisoners and they're experimenting and exactly
why I don't know they're developing something
new to maybe harness or whatever uh but what
it's doing with our main character of what our
main the damage our main charact because there our
main is in the boys it's the the boys themselves
and supers and the supers our lead supers are are
also the boys you know they are doing the the um
the mission of that yeah so that to me makes for
very compelling um you know putting up putting a
hole in in the in the vault plans uh but Johnny
please sorry I know I not stopped talking about
no it's all good I mean everything you guys have
said I I would Echo entirely and I think that with
the central mystery it's kind of I still feel
similarly to how I did before where it's like
it's a world where you know there's a nefarious
plot at hand and it's more about using that to
give the characters you know interesting ways to
develop and confront the scenario and show who
they are and uh and I appreciate especially after
this three episode chunk you know where we're
left off because we are left with this moment of
like you know bad things have happened and a lot
of you know significant events have gone down um
but like you know the the cat isn't quite out of
the bag and the [__] hasn't quite hit the fan
yet but I could see how now this could certainly
be that moment because with em yeah oh I see what
you did there I I understood that reference uh but
yeah like with Emma you know in this completely
compromised situation where it's either gonna
get worse for Sam and or worse for her too um I
think you know that's just like a great kind of
compelling start especially then when you have
that combin uh combined moment of Andre's dad
being like you drop this you know do not pursue
this I probably have sh like the last shot was the
Cliffhanger I was wondering where it would end for
all this buildup why it was three episodes and not
only did it look like a piece of Derrick Robertson
art Who's the artist and the boys but it also puts
us in like now we're into the second act of the
structure of like things are going to get worse
and conflict is rising well I mean beyond that
too the Marie join she's now like being welcome
I mean there's a team forming for now they exact
that's what was getting me like runaways Vibes
you know or like teen high school show like a
teen show this episode though especially The
Runaways parenting makes sense because yeah you're
so focused on both tiar and the interplay between
both and all the parents kind of have even though
it's not the same coordinated villainy an heir of
coordinated villainy what I'm so impressed by is
that we there's like what eight leads and I keep
like when you made the joke of uh and then just
to the right she's filming like that's believable
I really enjoy how well-versed all the supporting
characters are that I'm like this could build on
this could build on this or not and I really like
that it doesn't feel like it's coloring in the
numbers like watching this show I don't know how
the episode's going to end but I also don't know
how the second and third Act of each episode's
going to be and it's actually captivating
throughout like I've really struggled lately with
television cuz my attention Pain's getting worse
by the day and like I haven't once felt compelled
to check my phone I haven't once felt compelled
to think about the world like this show is like
the boys has kept me so engaged that the world
outside this screen is null and void for the
runtime and that is so rare in in entertainment
right now for me yeah I agree I agree I was
I'm really sucked into it when it's when it's
all um unfolding and it's minute by minute it's
not it's not like oh just the last five minutes
are like oh but it's the whole show is like
what's going to happen yeah and I think it's
a smart thing too that they that they do hearken
toward things you said 13 Reasons Why especially
with the Golden Boy plot line no I mean like from
from from the vague amounts I know from listening
to whyms rant about seasons of 13 recent just
like I think there's like flashbacks and stuff
totally and uncovering a mystery and like that's
I didn't expect him to stay in the show so much
but yeah the flashback getting there yeah it's a
solid device but I think also this show is nicely
pitched in that yeah it's using its perspective
very conscientiously but yeah it's also able to
without just being a ripoff of various other teen
and young adult shows embody that too to feel you
know adjacent to and certainly well within the
graphic graphic novel uh you know sense of the
boys but also yeah to occupy this separate tonal
space that is yeah pitched like I could see it's
like if you're a boys fan I I feel like you'll
definitely check this out but I could see some
people getting into the boys through this through
this yeah especially the younger like next wave
of because I remember being this age and feeling
isolated and then like these are my best friends
and then back to isolated these my best friends
and the show is capturing that but I also remember
being really pandered to by adults that hasn't
changed for I mean that's just life but but like
I remember being in your like late teens early 20s
where you felt like everyone was kind of pandering
to like yeah you're an adult now and then you're
like but why don't you let me do [__] like
this feels a lot like that and especially in this
parent episode where you can tell the moment where
they're like you're just using me or like this is
being and obviously like I said last week it's a
bigger scale because it's a superhero show but I
love how that alienation also feels like how do
the parents manipulate what they want into getting
their kid what they want yeah and I I do kind of
Wonder I mean from a business Optics perspective
because it's gen V they're pitching as like the
the you know it feels like you're watching young
adults on screen and I don't know if that might
cause a distance for audiences you know uh upon
before watching it like oh is this targeted for
a younger demographic this time you know because
like everyone on the boys is like like in their
30s and right and that where they're focusing here
that's just one question that pops up the other
thing that I really like is the message that every
Disney movie pushes now which is about you know uh
don't listen to your parents yep chart your own
path they're out to get you and uh three Luke uh
I think they did an excellent job with him here
because I thought he was just going to show the
way they've handled the perspective on when you
see Luke is he's just deranged he's kind of crazy
right now he's cracked and then when she shows up
with him you're like oh never mind yeah they even
introduce him upon her perspective Sam Luke luk
one to die yeah Sam's the one yeah my bad um names
are out of the three of us worst Sam yeah Sam you
think he's scary and and that he's he he can be
like Manic and maybe a threat unhinged and then
even when um again Emma tiny uh Emma Emma when
she shows up even she's terrified and the way they
capture it oh that shot through the cup to the cup
yeah that I now see a spider's POV every time I
might put a spider in thing I'm like I know what
it's like bro but it captures it captures it in a
way like oh he's terrifying but then as she gets
to know him you know you just see this boy who's
who's uh broken yeah L you see this sweetness and
and you could and it makes sense why they would
bond with each other like oh never mind they're
just a couple of misunderstood and like you said
like their trauma bonding felt real immediately
like I loved their trauma bonding right way yeah I
just love trauma bonding I mean you got the right
show for it the right Universe for it the boys
and gen a lot of trauma bonding any other bonding
is boring super surf level can't B through love
Disney movies Bond over pain have you met someone
without trauma my God they're not funny boring
they have no personality they probably have their
life together I don't care car live in LA that's
for sure so I don't know him the the the interest
is in the struggle all my friends that are doing
well back East with kids and stuff love to death
lack of conflict in your life got that white pick
fence go live your life over there you stay sane
we're going to watch genv and Trauma bond with
it I'm so impressed man this show is like up
there with the boys and I think the boys is one
of the best things to come out of TV in the last
few years so this is really impressive if this
sticks The Landing like this feels like one of
those shows where it can prove spin-offs can be
good much the way that like there was that that
phase where sequels were so bad I was like look
a good sequel like this could be like remember
spin-offs like this is so well put together what
it makes me wonder about the writer room too
because it does feel authentically youthful and in
tune with the youth without feeling like you know
greetings fellow children right you know so and
the language doesn't feel like it's heavy-handedly
like trying to be young but it's also not stale
No Cap Coy No Cap No Cap don't be sus this is
this is this show is straight busing alrighty guys
all righty Coy I got to get you out of here good
Boogie so ladies and gentlemen what did you think
about this third episode of the Gen V leave your
thoughts leave your thoughts down below um thank
you guys for being here and for being citizens of
the reject Nation get yourself some reject Peril
thanks Coy we will see you guys next week where we
also got Loki yeah oh we're back wait a minute L
on Thursday this on Friday I mean this is Friday
at midnight this Friday midnight that's spicy
all right oh Friday midnight all right remember
rest you don't dude Saturday no rest is not a
vo vocabulary gief you this is a retroactively
sponsored by the midnights will be I've gone back
to just grabbing old cans that I haven't thrown
out yet a little down just throw them all into
one big bucket and I'll just dump it on my head
what's up our uh 10 and UPS we have asked our uh
chat TBT here to uh Mar you guys a shout out with
Rhymes that incorporate a movie title or character
or TV series let's see what they have come up with
take it away John absolutely saury like Furby
in Gremlins creating Buzz that's all whims ooh
Ryan Smith smooth as myth in Troy revealing the
pith Adrien Tims bopping to hims in Sister Act
all about again the whims real nagas like real
sagas it's Star Wars full of Dramas had their
gear bringing cheer like cheers clear as beer
Ian Simon shining like a diamond in Oceans 11
with Vibes so vibrant s High Glover like Clover
and lucky number seven back uh bringing luck over
and over lucky number s gota watch it Kayla the
king like Leila singing and Almost Famous her
vibe is ringing Allan Ling hey even that rhymes
like bling in The Bling Ring sparkling and zinging
Kelsey like Gatsby in The Great Cat be classy
and Sassy Kar like Tiara in The Princess Diaries
sparkling with aura Eric K 39 like Con in the con
is on striking like ions my head hurts nickx like
flicks in netflex flashing those peex nice Juan
Longoria like Euphoria and Euphoria spreading the
glory I love the character of euphoria on Euphoria
static and like a tent in Mash so content Cliff
Rodriguez like whiz in The Wizard of o saring in
the bids oh they could have done better oh goat
Nation 18 like rotation in Revolution spinning
the sensation Lorenzo backer like a tractor in
cars pulling the factor differently saying like
a cane in house supporting uh the lane Marco tun
like a fun still and Fun with Dick and Jane
Rolling the thrill L an American Horse like
force and Air Force One powering the course simply
faded like jaded and Jade So Sophisticated SJ 94
like Shore and bayat washing the shore Justin
Martin like a martini and Casino Royale shaking
the scene what there's no rhyme there's just a
bunch of syllables there are like Rosie batty
Darth Yoda Order 66 like posie and Pushing Daisies
blossoming the Cozy FL Doran like torn in the torn
curtain weaving the yarn Colin like Rollin in
Rolling Kansas keeping it golden Philip J Smith
Jr like flipping flipper making the script Jen
Smith like Zen in Zen uh calming the den they
didn't even try Melanie LeBlanc like Swan and
Hillary and Jackie rank in the bank Ron in the
bnk M Melanie La blank like Swank and Hillary and
Jackie ranking the bank all right this is yeah
this is going to put a lot of writers out of work
I think yeah yeah yeah yeah knows how to write RS
it knows poetry it knows complex interplay between
you know concept this how the Pokemon came up with
the wraps of all the songs Just yeah here's 150
Pokemon make it rhyme thanks Chad DPT well guys
we appreciate you all for being here and uh stay
tuned next month to see what we can come up with
next with the help of our lovely computer
assistant love you all see you [Music] soon